thank you to add some Las Vegas
homeowners who use the most amount of
water will be paying more for it members
of the Las Vegas Valley Water District
met today approving new water rates the
more water use the more you will pay an
excessive use charge will affect the top
10 percent of homes water district
general manager John Ensminger saying
it's for the homeowners with expansive
areas of grass Turf that is
inefficiently watered and people who
don't follow a water in schedule he says
most homeowners will not have to pay
extra and Springer says other
conservation measures are going well
rules seasonal moving forward very
aggressively with the non-functional
turf the the community is responding we
have removed thus far that I should say
the community is removed thus far this
calendar year over 5 million square feet
of turf from the valley limiting a new
Turf has already been accomplished and
he adds Golf Course water budgets will
be presented to the board next month in
addition to pool sizes and septic
systems recommendations the new rates
take effect January 1st